welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and james gunn's suicide squad has
a new redband trailer for this
sequel non-sequel a trailer that got
steely dan
trending and it confirmed my discovery
of starro back in august's dc fandom
footage in the best possible way like
he's big now no one's gonna overlook him
i already gave my raw reaction first
time watching this trailer yesterday now
i'm gonna break down the trailer shot by
shot for all the hidden details that you
might have overlooked and reasons to be
even more grossed out by king shark and
weasel so
in case i accidentally reveal too much
about the plot or if the things i zoom
and enhance on make you puke
double warning for spoilers and triggers
here we go
you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behinds
these are dangerous people what are you
guys doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save me
it was a really good plan too well i can
go back inside and you can still do it
okay we open with half of task force x
rushing to save harley quinn from the
2016 suicide squad margot robbie
returned to harley quinn
vayla davis returns as amanda waller
joel kinnaman as rick flagg and jay
courtney as captain boomerang the rest
of that cast
will smith deadshot jared leto joker
killer croc diablo there's still
part of this continuity technically but
they won't be in this film
like either they died on past suicide
squad missions or some of them may be
hoping they get the jared leto treatment
and show up elsewhere in the restored
steiner verse either way james gunn has
said this movie's not a direct sequel to
the 2016 film but
also not a reboot just kind of a fresh
start that takes off using a lot of the
same characters in the same universe
taking its cues from john ostrander's
comics on this bus with flag
here is idris elba as bloodsport a
mercenary who famously shot superman
with the kryptonite bullet this next
guy's a bit hard to see because he's
invisible but john cena as peacemaker
uh patriotic dope who's actually getting
his own spin-off series on hbo max
pete capaldi as the thinker a genius
with telepathic powers david desmarchian
as polkadot man a goofball who can fling
his polka dots as weapons and tools and
king shark
it's mocap by steve agee who also plays
wallers tech in this movie
but he's actually voiced by sylvester
stallone hey pretty good
and daniella melchior is also with them
she's playing rat catcher 2. now flag
actually led a
separate team in other parts of this
movie that includes captain boomerang
flulaborg as javelin pete davidson is
blackguard melang
as mongal who's kind of an alien
superman villain
nathan filian has tdk which probably
stands for the detachable kid
his arms pop off and michael rooker as
savant
and sean gunn as weasel what a liquor
now posters for each of these characters
warn don't get attached
suggesting that we will see quite a few
of these folks die i'm guessing it's
going to be most of the
javelin boomerang team like they go in
they get mowed down right away and then
in comes the backup crew
now peacemaker complains that they're
risking the mission to save harley quinn
so if rescuing her right now is not the
primary objective what
is well look at those red yellow and
blue flags in the background of this
town
these are actually the same colors of
flags of a few south american countries
like colombia venezuela ecuador
but those countries always go from the
top yellow then blue then red
this is actually a fictional island
nation off the coast of south america
from dc comics named corto maltese or
corto maltese during world war ii this
island was captured by the nazis who
built this fortress tower it's called
juttenheim it's a lab where political
prisoners were experimented on
and actually turn into early metahumans
and now here in the modern era it is
home to starro
an alien parasitic hive mind from dc
comics a mechanized version of starro
actually showed up in the snyder cut of
justice league recently
and it's pretty fitting that a giant
star emerges from beneath jutenheim a
name that comes from norse mythology the
home of the giants
in this country presidente general
silvio luna played by juan diego boto
crowned himself leader of this country
he doesn't appear in this trailer he may
actually be under the control of starro
but his right hand man major general
matteo suarez played by joaquin cosio
does show up at another point leading
the revolt against them is
solceria alice braga so i think the
suicide squad's mission is to work with
sulceria
to topple luna and free the island from
the grip of starro
team one probably blew it harley quinn
got captured and now it's on team two to
clean it up
and notice how here they're all wearing
casual clothes i think this because this
side mission came up right as they were
taking the night off drinking and
partying also notice that king shark is
not in the wide shot of the bus as it
rolls past
i think it's just because they didn't
add his vfx to the exterior shots yet
but i'm loving guns camera work and
blocking like the whip pans in the bus
matching bloodsport tossing the gun
and then later the stagey warnings they
give the thinker one at a time
like gun shoots these movies like
live-action cartoons the frame is always
directed by the laugh
a close-up of mongal's rap sheet lists
her offenses massive homicide war crimes
crimes against humanity
destruction of property aiding and
abetting threatening something her
biostats list her as
alien in origin orange and unknown
age meanwhile harley quinn's charges are
kidnapping extortion destruction of
property attempted homicide
distribution of illegal weapons and
interestingly vigilantism maybe a nod to
her recent heroic turn in birds of prey
saving cassandra kane from black mass
and he may have seen this but harley has
a new shoulder tattoo that says
property of no one a replacement for her
property of the joker tattoo that she
had in the 2016 suicide squad she's your
own woman now she doesn't need no one
notice here when they try to save her
harley carries javelins javelin
pretty good sign that javelin probably
won't survive that first wave okay so as
we move ahead through the trailer james
gunn uses steely dan's dirty work which
is really a perfect track for this group
of mercenaries forced to do someone
else's dirty work and hating themselves
the whole time
like the amazing trailer for the 2016
suicide squad that synced everything to
bohemian rhapsody
gun does a bit of that here with savant
bouncing the ball around a cell
you know the deal
satisfying and i love how he has taped
up these color-coded x's
to know how to angle the ball so that
it'll just bounce right back to his hand
this guy's got a lot of time on his
hands blackguard exits the bathroom with
tp on his croc but look beside him to
the right looks like some dude on the
ground there
maybe a fellow inmate black guard takes
down i mean blackheart's name is
dick hurts maybe he nut checked him on
weasel's door reads brch maybe this is
all belle reeve correctional hospital
and i love how long
gun stays on this shot like we get two
solid
licks with weasel freezing on the second
lick his breath fogging at the glass
like a dog caught in the act and check
out his eyes they are naturally
insanely askew like he's just lost and
licking this glass
until he notices bloodsport looking at
him and finally they both lock in on
them now i love this ear the doctor who
plugs the implant into savant is
actually a cameo by suicide squad comics
writer john ostrander whom james gunn
uses an inspiration for this film and
notice how this time they implant the
explosive chip at the base of their
skull
instead of on their neck like in the
2016 film so like if waller hits the
button this time we can expect to see
a full cradle explosion you know
obsessively re-watching this stuff to
find all the easter eggs takes a lot out
of me so after i'm done i like to kind
of unwind with a nice glass of wine with
my fiance the problem is i have no idea
what kind of wine to drink i'm basically
just picking wine based on the label
i'm in the mood for a fancy font red
tonight or i'll drink a white cause it's
got a koala on it well like for me
there's bright cellars they use a quiz
to determine your taste preferences and
then they show you a list of the top six
wines that you're most likely to enjoy
from around the world they educate you
about wine along the way to help you
find your new favorites
something that's very helpful for
someone like me if you like your
recommendations and want to try them
they'll ship them straight
to your door and if you don't like one
of your matches brightseller's delight
guarantee
ensures that you get a replacement
bottle in your next box so this
is my second box from brightsellers i
rated the wines in the first box and
based on those ratings they sent me
these new wines
like this one this is called pet name it
comes from the columbia valley which is
in santa rosa california it's a
syrah has notes of plum raspberry and
smoke
a few years ago my apartment burned down
so everything i owned smelled like smoke
and everything i tasted tasted like
smoke i'm a man of smoke so i'm gonna
love this one so all you gotta do is
click on the link in the description of
this video and take this quiz yourself
and you will receive 50 off your first
six bottles when you use our link and
thanks again to bright sellers for
sponsoring this video
now in this team-up shot in front of the
u.s flag a little warning here
it might gross you out but weasel
totally has his um
parts dangling and the sun there just
one detail i think we can afford to miss
and good thing king shark wears shorts
all right moving on
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all going to die i hope so
oh damn so when king shark lifts this
dude the guy's legs kick up in a panic
but
notice when the first chomp down the
legs kind of just fall limp
meaning that that bite must have broken
the guy's spinal cord
oh my god and i love the jump cut from
king shark's nom nom to steve agey
spitting out his coke as if he is
reacting to his own motion capture but
hearing the voice of rocky coming out of
there
and in this briefing room of course
peacemaker takes diligent
notes and king shark proves himself kind
of the groot of this punch
also there's this creepy lurker and a
white shirt in the background shadows of
this room i'm gonna assume it's jean's
guy guy gets around
next clip we fail the mission you die we
find out any information you give us is
false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth yeah i
do love that public health psa from
harley quinn
if you cough without covering your mouth
someone may die now the thinker is a
super powerful villain so why bring him
on board in this mission
i'm thinking since the staro drones
operate on a hive mind that they might
need the thinker's telepathy to hack
into
and disrupt those brain waves you can
see on the thinker's character poster he
is swarmed by starros there
his right ear is injured and the nodes
on his right side are broken so he may
have been injured on his right side or
maybe they
intentionally disabled part of his node
so that they could keep better control
of him when they were implanting the
chip
okay moving on there's a shot of king
shark with bite marks
all over his body these could be from
star wars trying to latch onto him they
do have sharp teeth on their bellies
but one of those marks shows a cleaner
upper row
and a bottom row of teeth so i'm
wondering if these could be attacks from
weasel or maybe weasel with staro
latched onto his face but leaving his
mouth exposed on to the next clip you're
supposed to be decisive
and i've decided that you should eat a
big bag of dicks but this whole beach
was completely covered in dicks and
somebody said i'd eat every dick until
the beach was clean for liberty i would
say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans that's why mad men do what
they do yeah great character moment from
peacemaker here
but i love how in the back of the line
you can see the polka dots a polkadot
man glowing through the darkness he is
so practical
now as we move along there are more
shots of the gang partying presumably
this is before they get interrupted to
go save harley quinn polka dot man
tearing it up on the dance floor there
this elevator is weird
negative numbers to signify subterranean
floors and then a button for
dirty something assuming this is
hutenheim tower
these underground levels could be where
starro emerges from and then we get to
the true red band shot king shark
ripping a soldier in half
another shot i hate to zoom in hands on
but we gotta do it because there is some
cool detail in the gore here
exposed ribs and then one broken bone
dropping to the ground while the
entrails stringing between the two
halves but look at this the poor dude's
face
looks over at his own wrecked body so
king shark is a monster but i gotta
imagine this soldier must have done
something extra despicable to deserve
this mutilation in our eyes
let's move on to the next clip
[Applause]
oh my god we've got a freaking kaiju up
in this [__]
okay king shark right catcher two blood
sport harley quinn and polka dot man
are shaken by this giant pink and blue
appendage bursting up from the ground
an arm of starrow now before it all
comes down
look at this room it looks like the top
of yotenheim tower that looks like
german lettering on the walls it's
super blurry but it kind of looks like a
levusen
which i mispronounced probably but it i
think translates to
all c and then there's a skyscape
ceiling with a star
on it so maybe staro's been here since
the days of the nazis
watching this go down king shark gnaws
on a human head here
it's a skull maybe he coughed up that
skull of the guy that he nom-nommed
earlier and now he's like chewing on it
like a dog will chew on a bone that it
hacks up looking at you darla
disgusting now we get a look at this
appendage up close
and you can really see its beady
ecnoderm flesh i love that because you
know they could have just made it smooth
and gooey and slimy but they really did
some macroscopic photography
on the skin of starfish and then on the
screen behind a.g yeah that giant starro
looms over the compound he calls it a
kaiju liking it with godzilla which
makes sense
it crushes the car here and though we
don't see it in this trailer it probably
will release a swarm of starro drones
that cover people's faces
now tycho watiti is said to be doing a
mystery vocal cameo and many of us
believe that he could be the voice of
starro
if so i would just love to see a final
battle where it's
tyka's sarcastic voice booming down from
this thing you know what this character
doesn't even need to die i want a dc
cinematic universe where starro is
always around hey support this channel
by checking out our great merch options
at newarkstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars here on youtube for deep
dives and do everything you love thanks
for watching
[Music]
you